[Musique]
bonjour jérôme guedj bonjour et merci de
nous accorder cet entretien vous êtes
ancien député socialiste spécialiste des
questions liées au vieillissement de la
population le ministre de la santé vous
a confié une mission sur la protection
du grand âge dans la crise sanitaire
alors je dirais qu'on commence par ce
qui s'est passé dont les ehpad dans
notre pays c'était une guerre sans armes
un front sous-estimé avec des directives
peu clair voilà ce que disent
essentiellement les témoins ceux qui ont
travaillé dans ces établissements
aujourd'hui plus de la moitié des morts
dus qu'aux vide en france étaient des
personnes âgées résidant en ehpad
beaucoup parlent de tragédie qu'est ce
qui s'est passé et qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché qu'est ce que les pouvoirs
publics ont raté d'abord en effet oui
c'était une tragédie pour la conjonction
de deux raisons principales le fait bien
évidemment que le coc vide frappe
d'abord et avant tout des personnages
est très fragile et que par conséquent
qu'il soit très contagieux et comme les
ehpad sont des lieux de regroupement
utilisons ce terme de personnes âgées
très fragile dès qu'ils rentraient dans
un ehpad alors oui il était redoutable
et puis la deuxième raison structurelle
c'est que les ehpad n'était pas du tout
prêt à faire face à une crise de cette
ampleur et je vais même plus loin les
ehpad avant même cette crise était au
bord de la rupture les ehpad avant même
cette crise tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
depuis des années donc ça va bien est
difficile de savoir c'est la faute à qui
c'est la faute à la société dans son
ensemble qui voit dans l'ehpad un peu la
mauvaise conscience de son regard sur le
vieillissement mais ne lui donne pas les
moyens de faire face à ce à quoi il doit
aujourd'hui faire face les pattes
d'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus la maison de
retraite devant les gens qui rentrent
dans un ehpad c'est parce que il n'y a
plus la possibilité de rester au
domicile à raison son état de santé ça
veut donc dire que les gens qui rentrent
à l'ehpad ce sont des gens vraiment très
âgées plus de 85 ans de moyenne d'âge
avec des maladies chroniques parfois
graves en moyenne quand on rentre dans
les pattes on a sept ou huit pathologie
est depuis des années que disent les
personnels des ehpad il y avait une
grande grève en 2000 18 en mars 2010 8
en janvier 2018 et c'était donnez nous
des moyens pour mieux accompagner les
personnes âgées que nous accueillons
parce que il ya besoin de plus d'aidé
soignante il ya besoin de plus
d'infirmières il ya besoin de plus de
personnel d'animation de psychologues on
met des moyens en plus mais qui ne sont
pas suffisants pour répondre et donc
c'est la conjonction de ces deux
situations qui a fait que ça s'est mal
passé dans les ehpad au tout début de la
crise on a l'impression qu'on a laissé
mourir des gens tout seul sans rien
faire est ce que c'est le cas écoutez
moi je suis incapable de répondre à
cette question savez auprès de lille
vers ans je m'occupais de la lutte
contre l'isolément des personnes âgées
donc j'étais en contact bien évidemment
avec des gestionnaires d pad avec les
fédérations il ya des alertes qui on est
et qui ont été portés il est bien
identifié qu'il va y avoir un problème
dans les ehpad la seule difficulté c'est
que on est dans une dans une impuissance
à la fois en termes de moyens ce que je
viens de décrire on sait qu'il n'ya pas
de deux de personnel suffisant et
surtout la ressource potentielle eh ben
elle est mobilisée parce que de l'autre
côté tout le système sanitaire est
tourné vers la préservation du système
hospitalier il ya eu des situations très
disparates il y avait ceux des ehpad qui
travaillait bien avec des hôpitaux qui
avait des relations
d'habitude avec mais cela était possible
et donc pour lesquels ne serait-ce que
la la relation le diagnostic d'appui
médical il parfois téléphonique pouvait
exister un peu plus tard dans la crise
le gouvernement met en place des
hotlines gériatrique parce qu'il se rend
compte qu'à certains endroits il ya des
ehpad qui n'arrive pas à avoir accès à
ce conseil médical à cette orientation
voir à cet accès à des lits
d'hospitalisation donc une des
défaillances historique c'est qu'on a un
système médico social qui est très
cloisonné avec le système sanitaire est
dans une crise sanitaire le médico
social c'est-à-dire les ehpad et bien il
se retrouve face à cette cloison et à
l'absence de passerelles avec le système
sanitaire en ce qui concerne les
personnes âgées isolées
là encore il y avait beaucoup de
craintes comment ça s'est passé est ce
que le bilan est moins lourd que celui
des ehpad trésor vraiment au début de ma
mission quand olivier vers sommes là
confie une des inquiétudes c'est le
confinement va se traduire par une
amplification des phénomène d'isolement
or ces phénomène d'isolement on va se
dire entre nous il est suffisamment pris
en compte chaque année les petits frères
des pauvres produise un rapport très
documenté nous disant qu'il ya environ 1
million de personnes de plus de 75 ans
qui vivent dans une situation
d'isolement 300 milles qui sont en
situation de mort sociale est donc une
des inquiétudes que nous avions avec ce
confinement c'est que celle des
personnes qui étaient déjà isolé
auparavant allait l'être encore plus et
donc avec des risques sanitaires on
avait tous en tête le souvenir
douloureux de 2003 ou à la fin de la
canicule on a découvert au sens premier
du terme des personnes isolées morte
toute seule chez elle ou très abîmée en
terme en termes de santé la bonne
nouvelle si j'ose dire dans ce maelström
de souffrances liées à la crise c'est
que pour les personnes isolées à
domicile les saules les choses sont
plutôt moins mal passé qu'on pouvait le
craindre pour deux raisons principales
d'abord il ya eu un formidable élan de
solidarité dans l'ensemble de la
population et puis au delà de ces
initiatives individuelles et privés des
acteurs de premier plan qui ont été
notamment les associations je pense à la
croix rouge au réseau mona lisa aux
petits frères des pauvres je pense
également aussi au maire moi je le dis
sincèrement les maires ont été des héros
parce qu'ils ont fait preuve d'une très
grande agilité d'une très grande
inventivité et ils ont immédiatement
pensé à ces personnes âgées qui était
potentiellement isolé ou bien évidemment
toutes ces millions d'appels
téléphoniques qui ont été passées par
des caisses de retraites par des
mutuelles par des ccs par des
départements est donc le résultat d'un
réseau dans twilight entraide et il ya
donc la structuration le début truc
d'une structuration d'une politique de
lutte contre l' isolement j'espère
désormais que quand on passe on pensera
grand âge des vieillissements on inclura
maintenant systématiquement un volet
lutte contre l'isolément la plupart des
plaintes qui sont déposées devant la
cour de justice de la république où des
plaintes contre x à la préfecture de
paris ce sont des familles endeuillées
qui ont eu la mort d'un proche en ehpad
comment se fait-il qu alors qu'on sait
que ça va pas dans ce domaine là depuis
longtemps on n'est pas agi avant le
drame politique dans notre pays c'est
qu'il ya une sorte de déni du
vieillissement alors que c'est un
phénomène qui est là qui est prévisible
qui est aussi important que la
transition énergétique au climatique ce
que j'appelle moi la transition
démographique est un phénomène
parfaitement connus qui va être d'une
ampleur très grande dans les années à
venir rendez vous compte à partir de
2025 2030 c'est la génération des baby
boomers tous ceux qui sont nés après
1945 qui vont atteindre ces grands âges
plus de 80 ans plus de 85 ans et en une
décennie vont doubler mon passé de 2
millions à 4 millions levés le taux
d'actifs il ya un déni collective est un
des lourds intime aussi parce qu'on ne
vais pas l'idée de la mort elle n'est
pas la regarder en fait parfaitement
raison d'où vient ce déni collectif et
ce déni politique c'est aussi parce
qu'il ya une sorte de déni intime et
personnelle du vieillissement le vieux
c'est l'autre personne veut se projeter
dans cette situation alors c'est un
phénomène majeur le claude lévi strauss
dans une des ses dernières conférences
au collège de france disait qu'à
l'époque l'allongement de l'espérance de
vie pour lui est un phénomène
anthropologique aussi essentiel que la
sédentarisation au néolithique alors
maintenant vous vous appelez avec
d'autres à une tente de révolution de la
longévité vous en avez parlé aussi
importante que le défi climatique ce
sont des mots mais concrètement qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire j'imagine une remise
à plat totale et des ehpad et de
l'accompagnement des personnes isolées
du service à la personne c'est ça il
faut dans révolution de la longévité il
faut intégrer justement cette
phénomène là d'abord le prévenir
considérer que la ville doit s'adapter
au vieillissement quand on construit des
logements quand on aménage l'espace
public regardez dans la rue aujourd'hui
à plus de bancs publics on pense que
c'est une décision pertinente pour
éviter et encore je le pense pas que les
jeunes squattent ou que des sdf qui
reste d'abord pas très sympa je trouve
mais la conséquence indirecte à laquelle
personne n'a pensé c'est que les
personnes âgées qui ont besoin de
cheminées et de sortir de chez elle elle
ne trouve plus que tout les 100 ou 200 m
le nécessaire banc dont elles ont besoin
l'exemple est anecdotique on peut le
multiplier à l'envi donc le label vise
le logement les transports la vie
sociale la moitié des associations de
france et des conseils municipaux
s'appuie sur les personnages et donc est
d'abord cette logique de l'utilité
sociale de l'adaptation l'a souhaité au
vieillissement et puis quand le grand
âge arrive eh bien il faut que la
société elle soit solidaire c'est à dire
qu'elles répondent à la priorité
première demandé par les personnages
elle même ses pouvoirs vieillit chez moi
on a très peu de logements qui sont
adaptés on a des services à domicile
dans la tarification est archaïque c'est
le moyen âge c'est le dernier endroit où
on paye des salariés à l'heure et puis
on a des établissements on en a parlé
des ehpad donc on n'a pas assumé la
médicalisation et le fait qu'ils doivent
accueillir des personnes de plus en plus
fragile tout ceci nécessite une vision
qui n'est pas qu'une vision sanitaire et
médico-social moi je plaide pour que ce
soit un sujet totalement
interministériel il manque probablement
encore aujourd'hui une impulsion qui
vient du plus haut sommet je pense que
il faut un comité interministériel de la
longévité ou de la transition
démographique ou autour de la table on a
l'ensemble des ministres qui disent moi
dans mon département ministériel
comment je prépare cette révocation très
bien que le chantier il est immense et
il touche à énormément de se faire dans
notre société il va coûter cher combien
et qui va payer quand on regarde
attentivement les choses savez
aujourd'hui la france consacre 25
milliards d'euros à la prise en charge
du grand âge ça peut paraître beaucoup
comme chiffre devait le comparer à un
autre c'est un élément des 200 milliards
d'euros des dépenses d'assurance-maladie
donc de la sécurité sociale donc voyez
que c'est pas une somme totalement
inatteignable tous les experts estiment
que dans les dix années qui viennent à
l'horizon 2030 il faudrait mettre sur la
table 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires on me parlait des
faiblesses du système mais aussi de
bonnes nouvelles on peut être fier
d'avoir sauvé des vies les vies qu'on a
sauvé ce sont celles pour la plupart un
immense majorité des personnes âgées
choisir la vie et la vie de nos aînés
plutôt que l'économie est ce que c'est
un tournant morale qui va qui va au fond
décès des traces qui va avoir des
conséquences sur l'avenir moi je trouve
que c'est une très bonne nouvelle
certains ont pu s'étonner qu'on puisse
sacrifier l'appareil productif
l'économie pour protéger les plus
fragiles notamment les personnes âgées
au contraire je pense que c'est un signe
de maturité
civilisationnel on a remis les
vulnérabilités et les fragilités au
milieu du village on a considéré que ce
qui faisait société ensemble c'était
précisément la protection des plus
fragiles un autre choix aux requêtes
fait un choix très sélectif quasi
darwinien que les meilleurs s'en sortent
un choix hagist en l'occurrence qui
aurait consisté à dire ces deux groupes
ils ont fait ils ont fait leur temps et
bien leur vie ne vaut pas les efforts
qu'on pourrait faire non on a fait ces
efforts là et je trouve que c'est très
bon signe parce que ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas une lecture économiciste du
rapport à la vie ça veut dire que demain
on ne trie pas les gens dans l'accès au
don d'organes passé un certain âge ça
veut dire que demain on ne renonce pas à
des soins sans être dans l'acharnement
thérapeutique bien évidemment mais est
ce qu'on le voit quand même avoir ce
débat sur cette question du calcul coûts
bénéfices en fait un confinement total
choisir la vie de nos aînés plutôt qu'au
fond celle de nos jeunes qui risquent
d'être sacrifiés sur le marché du
travail vous avez entendu les baby
boomers qui ont plus de 70 ans
aujourd'hui certains ont pris la parole
pour dire eh ben il faut penser aux
jeunes arrêtez de penser à nous on est
moins prioritaire d'une certaine façon
ce débat il est sain ou alors vous
craignez la guerre d âge je vais vous
dire justement la société est là s'est
fracturé pour y ajouter en plus
la guerre des âges comme sujet de
tension alors même que ce sont dans les
solidarités intergénérationnelles et
dans le fait d'organiser ces passerelles
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées ses
créateurs d'emplois pour les jeunes les
personnes âgées sont des passeurs
d'histoires de connaissances
accessoirement de soutien à la vie
citoyenne dans les associations à la vie
politique dans les conseils municipaux
chaque semaine les grands parents ils
font autant de garde des petits enfants
que l'ensemble du système des crèches et
des aides et des aides à domicile donc
vous voyez on n'a vraiment pas à gagner
à cette confrontation au contraire par
la promotion de ces solidarités
intergénérationnelles par l'évacuation
de cette thématique que je trouve tout à
fait mortifère de mesurer la valeur
d'une vie alors en temps de guerre bien
évidemment mais nous avons eu le choix
et la faculté de mettre dans la balance
un coût économique et un coût humain je
pense à un moment donné le sens de
l'action politique c'est le droit au
bonheur et le plus longtemps possible
vous pensez vraiment tu auras un monde
d'après coronavirus concernant cette
question du grand âge vous êtes confiant
ou pas je suis je suis un optimiste
par nature donc je ne pourrais pas
imaginer que tout ce qui nous happe
était la figure s'agissant des
personnages à l'occasion de cette crise
ne soient pas pris en compte mais j'ai
aussi le pessimisme de la raison comme
disait gramsci qui est de m'inquiéter
sur la capacité qu'on a à oublier des
moments d'émotion la canicule de 2003 en
avait été un exemple et on est sur des
sujets où il n'y a pas de mobilisation
citoyenne en réalité il n'y a pas de
rapport de force qui existe
les personnes âgées dans les maisons de
retraite il ya personne qui parle pour
elle dans l'espace public et donc faut
que ça devienne un sujet de société nous
sommes tous des vieux en devenir ce
serait un triste monde d'après que de
pas prendre en compte sa et pas prendre
en compte cette révolution de la
longévité merci beaucoup merci vous est
en miettes
[Musique]